la session parlementaire est terminée à
Québec tout ce beau monde est retourné
travailler dans sa circonscription ça a
pas été une bonne session pour le
gouvernement le cafouillage à la société
la science automobile le projet de loi
sur l'augmentation du salaire des
députés et l'abandon du troisième lien
autoroutier sont autant d'exemples qui
nous disent que ça va très bien été ça a
fait oublier la baisse d'impôts du
budget vous rappelez vous il y a une
baisse d'impôts budget du mois de mars
et les investissements aussi dans
l'économie verte au sujet du troisième
lien écoutons le commentaire du Premier
ministre vendredi
le pont construire un troisième lien
c'est pas une solution blanc noir qui
est idéale des gens qui vont être obligé
de faire le grand tour par les deux
ponts donc c'est pas idéal donc comment
faire pour qu'il soit pas déçu
je vous demande conseil mais on a fait
le mieux qu'on pouvait
je trouve ça drôle quand le Premier
ministre demande conseil aux
journalistes comme ça en pleine
conférence de presse mais c'est parce
qu'il est il est probablement lui-même à
bout de d'arguments en tout cas pour
essayer de convaincre les gens qui sont
déçus d'accord Michel vous avez pensé
quoi de cette session parlementaire du
gouvernement effectivement une session
très mouvementée c'est moins qu'on peut
se dire mais c'est le choix du
gouvernement le gouvernement décidé
d'aller avec les mauvaises décisions au
début de son mandat
espérant que la suite des choses les
trois années qui vont suivre seront plus
positives très certainement
par ailleurs il y a eu beaucoup de
tragédies durant cette session là qu'on
pense à me queer Laval les inondations
le verglas là les feux de forêt et ça ça
touche les gens quand ils voient ça on
sait que les Québécois on est très
solidaire on est très sensible assez
réalité là et c'est là où monsieur
Legault est à son meilleur et le
gouvernement aussi pas uniquement lui
ils ont développé une expertise de
gestion de crise
liée à des événements hors contrôle si
vous voulez assez impressionnante
sincèrement on peut on peut dire ça
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que on est au deux extrêmes cette
gestion de crise qui est très empreinte
de sensibilité de compassion et des
dossiers des promesses brisées comme le
troisième lien par exemple
l'augmentation du salaire des élus qui
qui est en pleine période de négociation
avec les employés de l'État encore un
gouvernement qui a tendance à surtout le
Premier ministre cette fâcheuse habitude
d'arrogance dans certaines remarques
vous vous direz
pour lui dire que presque voler
l'élection quasiment et Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois lui disant que rien compris sur
l'augmentation du salaire des élus c'est
pas juste la bonne vieille politique où
il essaie de définir ses adversaires il
y a de la bonne vieille politique mais
ça quand tu es au gouvernement je trouve
qu'une des choses les plus
irritantes c'est l'arrogance quand on
est très majoritaire comme laque avec 90
députés donc on a connu le bon et le
moins bon durant cette session là il y a
évidemment les projets de loi sur la
santé sur l'éducation qui nous disent
que le gouvernement est extrêmement
centralisateur alors que c'est de nous
faire croire qu'il est décentralisateurs
qui peut prendre des décisions dans
toutes les régions très localement il
veut se montrer un gouvernement de
proximité mais encore là il fait le
contraire parle les projets de loi
eux-mêmes je termine en disant mais tout
le volet de l'adaptation climatique le
volet environnemental ou encore là de
tendance à souffler le chaud et le froid
on a des belles paroles on veut mais pas
avec les municipalités puis pas avec les
syndicats le contre-pouvoir là il y a
beaucoup de difficultés à tolérer le
contre-pouvoir alors comme je disais à
la fois des bons côtés mais de très
mauvais côté qui va falloir surveiller
de près
dans la prochaine année les mauvais
côtés dans leur gouvernance plus
traditionnelle d'un gouvernement qui
prend des décisions qui veut faire des
réformes et ainsi de suite alors que en
gestion de crise il s'en tient plutôt
bien
Jean-François vos réflexions
oui alors c'est bien la distinction
Saint-Michel ça dépend de la crise si
c'est la crise imposée par le climat il
faut une bonne gestion de crise si c'est
la crise qui génère eux-mêmes c'est
désastreux donc en fait ils sont ils
sont plus efficaces avec les désastes
naturels qu'avec les désastre kakis
[Rires]
j'aimerais savoir Sébastien nous ici on
fait juste commenter l'actualité tous
les jours je serai que il nous arrive
d'être
peut-être pas assez attentif mais quand
le Premier ministre dit vendredi à son
point de presse que la l'opportunité de
créer un troisième lien autoroutier
serait revu à tous les 5 ans est-ce que
vous vous aviez déjà entendu ça avant
moi je l'avais entendu de la bouche de
Genève Guilbaud je pense
d'ailleurs j'ai vu certaines de vos
collègues qui en ont fait tout de suite
une nouvelle ou un tweet bon je dis mais
c'est ce qu'il fallait dire à ce
moment-là
moi je les ai entendus dire écoutez on a
regardé le trafic sur le sur le pont de
pierre Laporte finalement ça ne justifie
pas un lien autour routier s'il y avait
dit le premier jour écouter pour
l'instant ça justifie pas mais on va
revoir tous les 50 moi j'aurais dit tous
les trois ans à leur place c'est bon si
ça aurait au moins susciter l'espoir ça
aurait dit ouais ça l'allure ils
attendent de voir puis qu'entre moins il
va être là est-ce que c'est je veux dire
il y aurait eu une meilleure logique que
cette fiction de dire que ils avaient vu
qu'il y avait un léger une légère baisse
alors que dans les documents c'était pas
exactement ce qui était écrit et puis
donc personne ne cru la réponse qui ont
donné mais s'il avait
vous savez c'est beaucoup d'argent donc
on va se reposer la question dans trois
ans
ils l'ont jamais dit textuel parce qu'on
comprend que des vraies raisons
finalement c'est que ça coûtait beaucoup
trop cher est-ce que c'est c'est la
conclusion à laquelle on en vient je
pense
aussi aussi parce que il y avait
beaucoup d'oppositions il savait pas
trop où le tunnel sortirait du côté de
Québec il y avait une autre puis en plus
le fédéral elle est pas payé 40 % puis
en plus peut-être que le fédéral allait
faire une étude environnementale quel
est l'interdire il y avait beaucoup de
choses c'est qu'il faisait en sorte que
c'est un paquet de troubles mais plutôt
que de dire ça ils ont dit il y a pas
assez de char sur le pont c'est pour ça
il y a pas assez de chance sur le pont
peut-être deux ans puis voir comment ça
se stabilise puis bon alors donc c'est
ça donc je dis là ils ont ils sont
arrivés avec la bonne réponse deux mois
trop tard ils ont payé très très cher
dans la région de Québec écoutez ils ont
fait en sorte que le PQ soit le premier
dans les intentions de vote à Québec il
faut quand même le faire sortir
pour faire ça mais donc sur la question
alors évidemment ils ont fait des bonnes
choses moi je pense que essayer de
réformer la santé puis l'éducation c'est
du courage politique ça c'est vrai bon
c'est pas facile on dit que la
commission parlementaire sur les refonds
du B se passe très bien et que monsieur
zubé fait preuve d'écoute envers les
acteurs d'abord et ensuite envers les
oppositions bon on va voir ce qui va se
passer à l'éducation ça a l'air à
s'engager de façon moins positive mais
on va donner la chance au coureur donc
ça c'est du vrai courage politique sur
le français ce qu'ils ont fait en
immigration puis en service français
c'est majeur c'est majeur dans les deux
cas c'est votre idée du courage
politique pour le faire évidemment il
manque
tout l'aspect des
temporaires qui anéanti tout le reste du
travail bon on va attendre à l'automne
ils nous ont dit qu'il y aurait quelque
chose à venir donc on va attendre mais
pour le reste moi j'ai trouvé que
l'arrogance constante de des ministres
face aux autres et Madame Guilbaud qui
fait un jeu de mots plutôt que du
concentrer sur son étude de crédit même
si c'est un détail dans l'ensemble des
de ce qu'on a entendu de refus d'écouter
c'est probablement l'anecdote qui parle
et le geste qui parle c'est
l'augmentation des salaires des députés
ou là ils étaient vraiment pas à
l'écoute des Québécois pas l'écoute de
leur sondage pas à l'écoute de personnes
sauf de leur portefeuille et ça ça leur
fait un temps considérant
une autre façon de voir puis bref aussi
c'est si il y avait une élection
aujourd'hui qui remporterait cette
élection et la réponse est simple c'est
la CAQ majoritairement donc avec cette
conclusion ça veut dire qu'ils ont eu
une excellente session parlementaire à
l'extérieur il y a pas baissé assez
ouais c'est ça mais en politique
mais pas trop en politique tu es
excellent quand tu gagnes et tu vas pas
grand chose quand tu pars donc si il y
avait une élection aujourd'hui la CAC
remporterait une autre élection de façon
majoritaire et leur défi puis on l'a dit
au tout début de la session c'est
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent démontrer
leur capacité de gouverner sur plusieurs
fronts parce que leur premier mandat a
été pris en otage par la pandémie ils
ont démontré pendant la pandémie
contrairement à d'autres gouvernements
provinciaux je dirais que leur gestion
de la pandémie c'est ce qui a reconduit
la CAQ à un gouvernement la majoritaire
avec plus de députés donc ils sont à
peine à leur première année de
gouvernance Jean-François vous avez fait
allusion réforme en santé en éducation
en justice ils sont en train
présentement de de
mettre les assises et sur qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont avoir comme bilan dans trois
ans donc début de mandat session
parlementaire ou le gouvernement sur le
plan global a gagné tous les points et
les oppositions le Parti libéral qui se
cherche toujours tu es solidaire qui est
à course à la chefferie pour choisir
une Cope parole suite à la démission de
Madame massé et le PQ qui à l'extérieur
de l'indépendance du Québec n'a pas
vraiment une valeur proposée pour
l'instant
on n'a pas dit que ça a été une mauvaise
session il reste largement en avance
dans les sondages mais il profite
probablement comme vous venez de
l'exposer Dimitri de la division des
parties de position puis il y a pas un
parti qui est pour l'instant
Jean-François en conclusion dans ce cas
là on va prendre une sabbatique jusqu'à
jusqu'à
vous que je pense Sébastien
parce que là est-ce que est-ce que la
session aurait pu être meilleur moi la
session aurait été excellente s'ils
avaient bien géré le troisième lien et
il y avait une façon de bien gérer ils
l'ont trouvé en retard bon s'ils avaient
bien géré le salaire des députés et puis
ici à l'émission on a pas arrêté de leur
donner des suggestions pour comment
mieux gérer ils ont pas écouté comme les
Québécois donc on aurait pu dire écoutez
il y a eu des dossiers difficiles ils
ont su être habile ils ont su bien les
gérer puis ils sont pas mis à
s'engueuler avec les journalistes puis
tout ça puis alors ça ça aurait été une
session excellente alors c'est sûr qu'il
serait élu là mais c'est pas une session
excellente mais je m'excuse
de la vie d'à peu près tout le monde
c'est pas une session excellente on va
voir ce que ça va donner pour la suite
du le Premier ministre était en pleine
forme vendredi moi j'ai été soufflé de
son énergie sa bonne humeur il était
content que ça finisse tu sais mais il y
aurait il y aurait pu avoir l'air plus
usé par la session mais non mais arrêtez
pas de nous dire que tu es là pour très
longtemps mais c'est seulement il
trouvait ça intéressant puis il
s'amusait bon ben tant mieux pour ce que
je voulais rajouter c'est passé en plus
il nous dit qu'il va être là pour très
longtemps puis vous avez vu qui était
sur sa droite et sur sa gauche
sonné qui l'envoyait un message à ses
troupes voilà exactement on me dit que
c'est peut-être pas si Jojo que ça là au
coq c'est au Conseil des ministres alors
peut-être que vous lui envoyez un
message pour dire hey moi je suis là
pour rester par ton papa il y a encore
trois longues années devant nous
grenouillez pas madame est beau monsieur
Alain barrette
en même temps c'est normal qui dit ça
maintenant si disait le contraire je
vais m'en aller
il veut que vous le sachiez ok d'accord
on le sait pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI